[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts I
feel like because I'm a comedian if you
don't understand my tone if people are
listening and they don't get that we're
joking Like Me and Bobby make a lot of
jokes on the show we're comedians it's
my job is to make jokes if you think
that what I'm saying might be serious
that's on you 100 on you that's kind of
my that's my perspective on Comedy as a
whole is like also watch uh my special
on Netflix January
he named it special after something he
never eats cheese Burger it's so funny
in your special the story about the dog
with the uh the girl with Down Syndrome
I love my dog and she's incredible she's
also a little bit of a pervert I'm not
gonna lie go check out Santino's special
go see my new special it's called
cheeseburger it's on Netflix why is it
called cheeseburger watch the [__]
special there we go you gotta watch it
to find out last week Andrew Santino
made his Netflix debut with the release
of a brand new hour of stand-up comedy
titled cheeseburger this special's been
the talk of the comedy world for days
now and seems like everyone from other
comedians to professional athletes has
something to say about Andrew Santino
cheeseburger cheeseburger so is 173 000
Die Hard comedy fans for their thoughts
on the new special the top comment was
from Michael [__] nice last name he said
I've seen him twice live and he's one of
the best Comics I've seen I don't think
it fully translated to a special but
still better than 90 of the [__] Netflix
pushes there's also a handful of
comments on here complaining about the
crowd or people that thought the crowd
at the tape and kind of sucked Nicholas
said Santina was great but you could
tell the crowd was less than awesome saw
it in it was good the audiences are
changing with the times and it's evident
and Chase said I enjoyed the performance
and loved how he turned claps into
laughs solid for sure with specials and
tapings you have to hit them you have to
just keep you keep hitting them and it's
hard too because with tapings the weird
thing is the audience is cognizant of
being filmed they know they're being
filmed it looks different than a regular
show the lights are [__] brighter
their seating is different you know what
I mean like we have to seat them around
cameras and it's all a part of that
world that changes how an audience feels
I don't think it really shifts the um
you know the the like the the laughter
or the Applause I don't think they're
Hamming it up or anything but you I do
always remember they're like they know
they're being filmed right there's a
sign out front that's like yo your
likeness may be used on this special on
Netflix you're saying yes by sitting in
this seat that you might be on camera
yeah I try as hard as I can to not show
anybody you know most of my fans are
very very unattractive so I just know I
mean
also the clip that this is from pardon
my take I'm not sure how many of you are
familiar with that podcast but later on
this interview big cat goes on to say
this I wish you know how the NBA has
like um every like the the off season is
almost like better sometimes than the
season because of like the drama and
everything oh yeah I wish we had someone
who was reporting on the comedy scene
would there be just oh that's
interesting because like I know that
there's clicks that I don't understand
and people who don't like other people
if you're familiar with this Channel at
all you're probably laugh during that
clip because that's literally exactly
what we do here so please sell the PMT
fans out there let big cat know about
joke world that we already exist maybe
he'll even subscribe maybe he'll even DM
the Instagram for a free sticker right
off the bat cheeseburger is one of the
most eye-catching or ear catching names
that I've heard for a comedy special in
a while it's confusing at first why it's
called cheeseburger but the meaning
reveals itself about halfway through the
show regardless of the meaning though
some people hate the name cheeseburger
and some people loved it this guy said
it was a very tasty cheeseburger that
had 37 likes Nicholas said hahaha
cheeseburger oh my gosh Santino you
silly little dog how does he come up
with this stuff I'm assuming that was
sarcastic so that's why I read it like
that but trash can Chris like the name
he said great special we're all just
cheeseburgers so what I'm saying is I'm
I'm promoting my special comes out
January 10th yes on Netflix Netflix why
I did it Netflix watch my special on
Netflix January 10th and then you have
to have something in you to get a
Netflix special you can't just be white
no no no no no no it's it's you have
some time
I showed him a guinea [__] is that the
name of the special I wish is it getting
retrospect man I wish what is it the
name of the special is called
cheeseburger cheese I swear to God
people will see it they'll understand
why I don't want to give away why
there's a it's a there's a thing in the
middle that tells you exactly is it
because when I got the cheeseburger you
put me in the special uh yup is that why
you're a video it's just footage of you
eating a cheeseburger in my car for an
hour now of course whenever a comedian
comes out with a new special nowadays
people naturally compare it to the humor
level of their podcasts especially guys
like Theo Von Tim Dylan or Andrew
Santino who are all used to seeing once
or twice a week performing very high
level comedy on their own shows this guy
said although I've been watching the
pods this is my first real time seeing
his stand up and I was blown away genius
another commenter said I'm sure a lot of
people share the same thoughts as me but
I can't get into a stand-up but podcast
wise I think he's funny could be that
he's better on his feet like Theo Von
another person said I'm a huge fan of
him as a podcaster probably more than a
stand-up to be honest but the special
was very solid in my opinion much better
than his other one that's on Amazon
Prime I think I saw him live last year
in San Francisco and it was great what's
your your last stand up I don't know if
it was the last special idea but it was
on I saw it on Amazon the other day oh
really um
on you had the uh the one with the teddy
bear in the back or the bear in the
background Chicago Bear in the back
cargo background yeah um that was very
funny check it out what's the name of
that one again that was called home
field advantage that was in Chicago
right shout out at the Vic that was many
moons ago I would say watch this one
first yeah okay watch cheeseburger that
was years ago I it was fun you know it
was on Showtime I did a deal with
Showtime because I had a TV show with
them and then you know it was they were
quick to pull the trigger I didn't they
were like we have to shoot a special
like very fast and I had a good time it
wasn't it wasn't my favorite this thing
that I put out now uh is one of my
favorite things as you can probably tell
most of the reviews on this special are
very positive but there's still a few
fans that didn't enjoy some of the
topics or premises in cheeseburger
specifically jokes that had more
divisive subjects like covid or politics
Garrett said couldn't get past the covet
[__] covet isn't funny to me Justin said
I think he's funny reacting in the
moment than what he is on the special
and to be clear he's one of my favorite
hosts and guests on pods just didn't
feel natural to force bits on kovid
Trump Biden prostate exams Etc we all
know prostate exam is a very divisive
topic and Chris said I have no problem
with comedians poking fun at Politics as
long as he's on both sides now with that
being said I have not seen the entire
special what I did see was him
insinuating that someone should have
tried to assassinate Trump that's not
cool I will say to the last commenter
Chris he did go after both sides and had
just as many buying jokes as he did
Trump jokes in fact honestly I'd say the
Biden ones were even funnier than the
Trump ones Biden
no thanks
yeah his bio pick
what are we gonna do about Ukraine Mr
President well you gotta you gotta
understand
what part of the reason I've never been
on a uh you know growing up in
Connecticut
blacks smell funny
that does it for this video thank you so
much for watching please let me know in
the comments what you think of Andrew
Santino cheeseburger and if you haven't
watched it yet you can find it right now
on Netflix other than that be sure to
subscribe to joke world right now and
turn on the post notifications because
we're coming out with Chris's Stefano
try not to laugh at some point soon
maybe at the end of this week even so
you gotta have the post notifications on
so you don't miss that that'd be very
embarrassing if you missed that almost
as embarrassing as big cat not knowing
that there is someone reporting on the
comedy news a whole Channel dedicated to
it joke world so reminder to go hit up
big cat on Twitter and Instagram really
bother him just share him the the
blessings of being a joke World
subscriber say things like oh my life
has never been better since subscribing
to joke world oh my penis has never been
larger since I started following joke
world oh if you don't follow joke world
bad things might start happening to your
family that you can't explain maybe
Ransom notes start showing up oh the
Bears will never win a game until you
follow joke World Justin Fields might
break his leg if you don't fall joke
World stuff like that that would really
bother big cat if you don't listen part
of my take none of this makes any sense
but I do I'm a big fan of theirs that's
why when I saw him say that I was like
what the [__] dude it's us we're we do
that we follow all the comedians report
on all of it the ends the outs of the
comedy game
joke World comedy news coming Monday
other than that
thank you again for watching
foreign
[Music]